what are feminine traits nurturing soft
caring playful empathetic compassionate
vulnerable so when we're talking about
healing
like all the things you guys listed none
of them got you to that
like tastes like getting rid of people
for six months doesn't make you more
nurturing soft caring playful and
pathetic going on a trip doesn't make
you more nurturing soft caring playful
and pathetic compassionate and
vulnerable
yeah do the opposite yeah it does the
opposite
but that was the inclination to no
relationship but that's exactly my point
let's say you feel more confident here
but it's to a point where like you're
now shutting like you're more masculine
yeah
that's made you a more confident and
better person than yourself but as a
partner he might not be looking for that
woman who's too loud too in his face
it's again because we become the men we
want to marry because we like confident
men they don't they're guys are into
confident women they're into shy women
that are like reserved
doesn't mean you're better i think it
says the latter because when i go
through spiritual experiences etc i
become way more tolerant because now
it's less about me and it's more about
like i see why you did that i see i
understand this so i can handle this
better so we don't have to argue we have
to fight i get it
um so if you come out of his so-called
spiritual experience and you're actually
less tolerant of everyone around you
that gives that's again lends more
credence to the idea that it's more of a
narcissistic ritual it's more like but
that wasn't what i was talking about the
spiritual the cutting off thing had
nothing to do with spirituality at all
it was more about
clean like dealing with the noise that
was in my head it had nothing to do with
like spiritual stuff that was for me but
the whole the whole spiritual thing is i
think
often serve as a really good way to not
be accountable because spiritualism is
relative like you could make a lot of
cases and say you know listen to jada
pink and smith right
she can validate hanging with august all
day
okay she might not be a good example but
they're common and so this is this is
common whenever i hear two girls talk
about like spiritual experiences i'm
like just say you're 304. no
i just
and i'm not i don't know you so i i'm
not saying you are i'm just saying this
is i've talked to so many people in the
last six months that these are like
patterns yeah i don't know like people
that i know that are spiritual i don't
know tons but they all seem to have some
sort of level head and i know what you
mean by you're saying that people could
just say oh well i'm spiritual and dead
and they can push that onto that but
there are there are people who are
opposite sorry there are people who
are not like that there are people i get
what you're saying about being tolerable
or more tolerant
but sometimes that comes with stepping
away from the noise realizing okay what
can i do what am i sure of what can i
give what can i take back what can i
keep from us what can i give it's not
just about ego but i get what you're
saying as well
it's a give and take it's a balance of
both
if that makes any sense you look very
confused
i understood what you said okay
do you have are you sure yeah
don't hold back don't go back come on
come on
i can see a butt um yeah i understand
that but to me it just sounded like a
need to be right it kind of it kind of
just sounded like
um
you know
trying to get out the fact that
spiritual practice breeds tolerance and
love
more so than anything else and it
minimizes self
and so if that understanding if you say
talk about that story i hate to be
personal
to me most of the key points of that
that your story your spiritual journey
or healing one it didn't make you
more loving it didn't make you you just
talked about yourself a lot you said you
know me me you know that kind of thing
it didn't make you more tolerant but i
know spiritually that other experience
was something else
but i think spiritual connects to
everything like we have a pattern and
you can see it in our lives so your
healing journey isn't disassociated from
that action whether it was before or
after you're saying everything is
interconnected it's interconnected and
so
you know
yes you need you need time alone but
um
cutting people off again it it even
sounds like a bit of a pain i need to
focus on the right things basically yeah
it even sounds like a power play like
you never hear someone a piece saying i
cut people off would you think i meant
by cutting people off for me it was just
them not having access or availability
every single day throughout the day
sorry well when you when you hear that
that doesn't sound feminine nurturing or
soft but i am feminine nurturing i don't
think well you don't i'm saying you
don't come across that way because of
the words that you say but that's
because i'm able to articulate i'm i'm
intelligent so
and i don't think it's a bad thing for
me to say i'm intelligent but if i'm in
a man's presence or if i'm with someone
who i'm romantically connected with
my air my aura and how i i am is very
different so if we asked your axes would
they agree yeah okay and they my ex
watches this show so hopefully he's
watching any comments
whoa
he told you to yeah he was the one who
was like yeah oh yeah
you said your order would change and etc
but you didn't surely it's other
people's like that's like okay it's kind
of like if a man said i'm super
masculine but only when i'm around women
but so so like that's like if a guy said
like it sounds like crazy because like
if a guy if a guy comes in he acts super
like feminine right and he's like hey
like hey girls then he's like look at i
am super masculine but only when i'm
around victoria's secret models i get
what you're saying but i'm in a
situation right now where i have to
think and i have to articulate myself so
therefore
maybe do you know what maybe that's my
alpha side i don't know maybe that is my
alpha side i've run a business so i have
that alpha streak but at the same time
i've been with men who are quite alpha
and they're like they've pointed certain
things out to me
so i've learned not only through what
i've seen at home with my mom and my dad
but i've also learned through those men
and through my own journey to be more
feminine so
i'll be about loving energy it's about
patience it's about
it's about all these kind of compromise
and everything you say seems to be more
around
you know
you
you kind of you know realizing power in
some way so
you know you say you're intelligent and
you're you've had a business and you cut
people off and
no but you're now listing your aura is
like different in other people it's all
a lot of affirmations and words you you
tend to you you know what to say but
feminism
isn't like i guess yeah it's a way of
being like it's love in it like you can
tell you can tell when someone's
feminine but no one can tell me they're
feminine that doesn't mean anything for
everyone who knows me who experiences me
will tell you otherwise
so
because you know right now
we're here experiencing you know
remember you said sometimes you just
have to listen yeah but i'm saying like
if if everyone in the room is saying one
thing you don't think that
but this is the first time i'd be
interviewing yeah yeah yeah so
yeah but you know i guess that again
proved your point of me not listening
yeah avoid butts and try and you know
yeah it's not even just that it was also
you basically that's what i'm saying it
was my whole point of like he's
basically saying that all your points is
more like it's like a bit self-centered
whereas it's less as like me being a
partner so that's what i'm saying it's
like you being
all these qualities
is not necessarily like appealing to
like a man or to a relationship but i
get what you mean in terms of saying
it's better you but that's the overall
like everyone disagreeing with you i
feel like they're basically saying it's
like but to a man or to like a
relationship yeah it's not bringing much
value and you're absolutely right
because you asked me in the beginning
what is my status and i said it's very
weird and it's very complicated right
now i don't feel like i'm in the best
space to be in a relationship because
remember i just said six months
everything was off
i know that i'm still not ready fully i
know what it feels like to be vulnerable
i know what it feels like to be
com to compromise i know it feels like
to listen and all of that
i do not feel like right now right now i
just feel like i have to just focus on
me and everyone's journey is different
everyone gets to a specific place in
their life and i think as women we are
so conditioned to be like you must give
you must be loving you must be nurturers
which is what we are naturally by birth
or whatever but i think it's also part
of self-preservation if my cup is empty
i can't pour
i need i need something for me too if i
mothers they say what do they usually
say my mom usually has time for herself
every sunday where she focuses on her
and during the rest of the week she's
able to pour into everybody in the
household and she i don't think she'll
be able to do that if she didn't take
time for her so would you say you're
still healing
there's that word again
i need to define that today man recovery
yeah because i say yeah
so technically it's not linear right